welcome back to las vegas now on this
founder's day it is time for a real
estate update with palacios realty they
want to help you make the right purchase
before
your dream home take a look we love
talking about this crazy real estate
market of ours
what is going on i know people are
asking you a lot
should they wait to buy a home if they
can't afford their dream home just yet
right
the dream home is the goal for a lot of
people yes but
you know unfortunately the way the
prices are going it's pricing some
people out of the market so
you know in some cases uh it is actually
smarter to buy now
when you think about it the appreciation
level that they'll get
just by buying now will outperform any
level of savings
that they can do over the next few
months so yeah buy something now
and if in a month or a year from now you
need to sell because you do find that
dream home
yeah take advantage of it you know
there's no rules against
paying that off especially if you're
getting a government-backed loan
prepayment penalty is nice
easy uh there's no penalty for that okay
but what about down payments people are
worried about that right
yeah so for the second home some people
feel like they might have to put down 20
at this point but that's not the case
if you are purchasing with a
government-backed loan and this is going
to be your primary residence meaning you
found your dream home and you're going
to move
well then you can use the low down
payment options of fha and conventional
loans
and in addition to that there's down
payment assistance programs to even help
in that same transaction so it just
depends on the situation everyone is
different but you just gotta
you know talk to a professional intent
no no uh shameless plug right there but
okay you mentioned
the pro the assistance program what is
that you wanna give us more details on
that
absolutely so the down payment
assistance programs um
typically people are asking about well i
got i want to get the first time home
buyer program
well yes that is one portion of the of
of those options but down payment
assistance is available to anyone
who's going to use this for their
primary residence if you are a teacher
there are 7 500 available as well as
under
uh rate the the rate can go under what
the market value is
first responders heroes va's military
all of them have different programs
available to them that you can use
the key factor though in all of that is
working with a lender
who encourages you to use the down
payment assistance programs because they
are then focused on your success
and not their commission keep that in
mind okay and jared while i'm focused on
buying my dream home um will inflation
affect the housing market you know
fantastic question
the the issue of inflation is happening
right now we are
dealing with hyperinflation it's been at
two percent over the last
40 years and in may it jumped up to five
percent
we're seeing it across the boards
between you know lettuce eggs wood
doesn't matter what it is there's uh you
know a backlog
and uh what is it mainly delays and
challenges uh
to reopening the economy so uh real
estate is i
ironically one of the best ways to
protect your wealth
cash is not king in this environment you
need to put it into something that will
be able to survive the inflationary
period
and this is where homes really come into
play so buying a house now even
especially with a low mortgage rate will
be an advantage for you
all right give palacios realty a call at
six six 702-333-6666 they have a special
offer for you as well if you buy or sell
through palacios realty and mention this
segment
for you get covered cost of estate
planning that's wills and trust
so really helpful there las vegas now
will be right